what's up GQ this is trey songz and
these are my tennis injures
item number one would be these two bad
boys here man let's show you how to do
it you got black orchid you got okay so
like this one is a little more masculine
this one has a little softer scent so
they kind of come together beautifully
everybody asks me what I wear and I
never tell them but I figured GQ wanted
to know I should tell you
so it's time for it this is a scented
candle
number 26 little bow that these are all
around my house at home so when I'm on
the road you know Hotel the hotel tour
bus I'd love to have this smell because
it makes me feel like I'm in a familiar
setting it smells really clean and it
takes over the room like in the hotel
like you could smell my room from like
the elevator and it's also good for like
alleviating other smells that's allowed
these are naturally soothing I'm reading
the organic natural herb cough drops I
used to love halls and this is no distal
all's in case y'all want to send me
something for free we call this much
more natural it's longer-lasting you
know you're singing a lot on the road
and you know you're out late night you
waking up early don't promo press
whatever have you these kind of keep
your voice and you throw it in a good
condition so I have to recall the photo
to me down I need a life so clock series
these are my headphones audio technica
ath em 50 X's when I first started I
would use them in the studio and I love
the way they sound is so much kind of
like a real genuine sound that you would
hear like in a car or places you listen
to music I make the records in the
studio I listen to the mixes and masters
and these as well so always keep a pair
of these in my book bag and like four
pair in the studio
much like the candle I showed you
earlier central 26 amazing fragrance if
you take like a long trip in the
bathroom and it's not me at all but you
know you want to depend on what kind
what kind of damage you did is it a
spent or like who don't go in as it pops
from Friday bad this does a really good
job nice and fresh what I have here is
kills ultra facial cleanser and ultra
facial moisturizer this is obviously to
clean the face and this is obviously to
moisturize the face I have kind of oily
skin if I wash my hands I have to
moisturize them immediately for my face
I wash my face probably three times a
day so I use this three times a day
this is kills creme de coeur I don't
know if I'm saying that right it's just
lotion look at the hand before Kiehl's
notice the hand moisturize but not well
moisturized look at that caramel skin
shine it now look at those Hey look at
bicep
get pay for this [ __ ]
this my friends is an iPhone I use this
one mainly for listening to music it has
a regular phone jack which means you can
charge your phone and listen to music
without having a adapter fees which I
love I don't use it for much else
because it's the older version
listen to mixes listen to music under
the rough dude is gold-plated
baller my grandmother's name is rose
right and I lived with her throughout
high school and it was in her yard that
I learned to trim and prune roses it was
something I didn't want to do she very
much loved to have me do with her so the
older I got the more I appreciated the
time you would spend so I grew a love
for roses having them in my dressing
rooms having it on my hotels cuz once
again just like the candles and innocent
a family picture if you will things like
that it brings familiarity to where you
are I'd love to have roses relax I was
young I was like 14 I tried to get at
this girl she said where's your watch I
don't have a watch she said well my
father told me any young man should have
a watches so he knows what time it is
and what's going on in the world I don't
even know who this girl was but it was
it was something that stuck with me and
as I became a man like men that I
admired JC Kevin Laue salió corn
cause it like they they all had a great
watch collection from the simplest watch
every day watch to like elaborate
watches like this well to be nice watch
this is not the idea I had they asked me
to put it on for you guys she cute I am
trey songz and this has been fun I can't
wait to see you again let me know if you
use any of my essentials so I can talk
to these people that I've sent money
towards
[Music]